i'm just like what
i wasn't even really offended i was just
shocked
that somebody could say something so
blatantly ignorant and racist and
unprofessional
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dani
and i'm a licensed architect in
beautiful vancouver bc so
this happened to me a few years ago at
my very first architecture job here in
vancouver
and so we were designing these offices
for
a municipal client but
everything was very very very
new for me um i didn't really know what
i was doing
and i made a lot of mistakes and i had
imposter syndrome
and i was generally just very insecure
about my abilities
anyways for this project we were
specifying
a ceiling product and i won't say what
exactly that product is because it might
expose this individual
so uh typically when we specify products
we
call the manufacturer and
the rep from that company will give you
some of the information about the
product and so there was this one
particular rep
that was helping me and uh honestly
like every time we were talking he was a
little
like tmi you know just a little bit too
much
personal information that i didn't
really need to know you know here
um at least here in the west coast um
we do a lot of small talk so you know
you start off the conversation with like
how's it going
how's your day oh it's like raining cats
and dogs here
i hope you're staying dry and
you know you try to build rapport with
this person before you
jump into business and um
like every single time he would just
dive a little bit
too far into his personal details
and um so i thought that was kind of
weird
and so one day he came over to the
office to
show me a bunch of their samples and
even before he got to our office he
called and he was like
oh i'm stopping by this office this
office this office
and oh yeah like they all love me there
so um yeah i'm just trying to paint you
a
image of this person and so
he like finally got to our office and of
course
this was the first time that we were
meeting like face to face
and he was like this big white dude
and his energy was kind of off
and he was kind of just like standing
there and i was like
hi i'm danny
and you know typically when the rep
comes they're like super friendly they
shake your hand
and like he didn't really reach out for
a handshake
this was before copen and so i was like
oh hey
i'm demi and you know whatever
so we sat down at the table and you know
it was just me and him
and he was showing me their product
and the whole time he was like making it
seem like
he was doing me a huge favor like
oh don't worry you can keep all these
samples and brochures
and i'm like no we're okay like we don't
have enough space in the office
and he was like no no no i insist you
can keep it i have plenty
so at first
i don't know that was kind of annoying
because i wasn't saying no
just to be polite like we literally were
actively trying not to
hoard materials in the office because we
didn't have enough space
and so we went through all the materials
and i asked him a bunch of questions
about the materials and
he kept saying things like oh yo like
i'm here for the weekend
um he was from calgary and he was like
oh my schedule is all
free if you wanna show me around
and um of course like at that point i
kind of knew he was
trying to hit on me and so
i'm just you know trying to like get
this person out the door
and he keeps going like oh yeah like we
have
tons of different types of samples in
our head office in calgary
like if you ever come visit i can show
you around and i can show you around the
city
and so i was like no i think i'm
good for now and so i was like okay well
thank you so much for coming all the way
here that was really helpful
and um i think i got all the information
i need
and i think i have a meeting now so um
you know just like trying to keep it
professional
and so um i got up
and i'm like ushering him out the door
and and he's like
wait wait wait
i'm like okay oh god what's he gonna say
next
and he like looks at me and he pauses
and he's like wait wait i gotta ask
what kind of asian are you
i'm just like what
and like before i can even answer he's
like
[Music]
and i i just kind of laughed i was like
okay thanks bye so
um so i closed the door
and i was just like flabbergasted that
this
even happened like i was i wasn't even
really offended i was just
shocked that somebody could say
something so
blatantly ignorant and racist and
unprofessional
but i think i was just more upset
about like wondering um like should i
have said something
how should i have dealt with that
situation like oh my god what's wrong
with me
um like how can i be taken seriously as
an architect if i
don't even know what to do in a
situation like this
um and so i was kind of like standing
there just like
running that scenario over and over in
my head
and i turn around
and i see my co-worker and she's like
laughing her head off
and um i think in that moment i just
realized that
like my head was so wrapped around
me and like what i should have done
because i was so insecure to see that
um i was starting to turn
the problem into me when it was like
obviously
this person who was the problem and i
was just like so
wrapped up in myself to see that this
was like an objectively
kind of funny situation and so i
started laughing and we just both
like sit there and laugh for like a good
five minutes
and you know she was this new senior
architect
and she was someone that i really
admired and like we
never really had the time to bond so
that was like
in a weird way kind of a nice bonding
experience
and so what i also realized
then is that you know it's not really
worth
me getting mad about you know we can
just decide to never use that company
like
this guy this company
just lost a multi-million dollar project
and like all of our future business
and i will not recommend this company to
anyone i work with
um and i think someone who is like
ignorant and unprofessional and
objectifies women
they're eventually gonna get weeded out
as
more and more women and more minorities
move into
like decision making positions that
being said
i do want to be a good role model and
like help
improve the industry for all the young
women coming into it
so maybe like the better way for me have
been
to like sit him down and explain to him
that it's not appropriate to talk like
that
and you know maybe if this had happened
to me now
um i would have done that because i have
a little bit more
self-worth and like less patience for
things like this
but the reason i'm telling you the story
now is because
well first of all i think it's kind of
funny and
because i think sometimes like we can
get really wrapped up in our own heads
and our own insecurities to really
see things clearly and you know this is
not the only instance when
like i have somehow found a way to beat
myself up about
a situation that was like obviously not
my fault
and now i'm just trying to be a little
bit more conscious
of that little subconscious
self-doubting part of my mind
and try to catch it whenever it starts
to creep in
so i would encourage you guys
to try doing the same if you have the
same problem
like monitor your thoughts and
you know try to look at the scenario
objectively
if you have the opposite problem where
you're always blaming other people
that's another problem of its own
so if you enjoyed the story remember to
hit that like button
and let me know in the comments if
you've ever been
in a situation like this we will return
to our regular programming next week
but in the meanwhile if you're looking
for some
actually valuable videos check out my
videos
like how to present case studies or
some of my architecture projects i'll
see you guys next time
bye new dude
you